ahora vamos a hablar de uno de los super
ones más famosos y este es el o perón la
que es parte del genoma de la e coli y
la que se está refiriendo a la lactosa
por lo que te puedes imaginar que
codifica para genes involucrados en el
metabolismo de la lactosa y
probablemente ya esté familiarizado con
la palabra lactosa es un azúcar que se
encuentra en la leche algunas personas
son intolerantes a la lactosa es decir
que tienen problemas para digerir la
lactosa
pero en general para que una célula
pueda hacer uso de ella tiene que ser
capaz de absorber la lactosa tiene que
poder dividir la molécula en azúcares
simples que pueda utilizar como
combustible y eso es para lo que
codifican los genes en el lo perón lac y
solo como un ejemplo el gen laxe está
justo aquí codifica para una enzima que
ayuda a dividir la lactosa en azúcares
simples
en la que codifica para una enzima que
permite la absorción de la lactosa a
través de las membranas celulares
el gen luck es un poco más interesante y
un poco menos comprendido pero la idea
general es que estos tres genes están
involucrados en el metabolismo y la
absorción de la lactosa y es 1 perón por
lo que aquí tenemos a nuestro promotor
que es donde nuestra arn polimerasa se
va a unir y también tenemos otros sitios
por acá está el operador que es donde un
represor como el represor la podría
unirse y por aquí está el sitio cab o el
sitio se ap se le llama así por su
nombre en inglés que travel light
activator program que se traduce como
proteína activadora de cata bonitos
proteína
activadora
d
cata por litros
y te puedes imaginar que este es el
sitio donde una proteína llamada
proteína activadora de cata bolitas se
puede unir y quizás actuar como un
activador así que una vez explicado esto
vamos a pensar en diferentes escenarios
vamos a pensar en un escenario donde la
e.coli se encuentra en un entorno donde
no hay lactosa
no
y 2a
entonces qué crees que pasaría en este
caso y muchas de estas cosas tienen
mucha lógica si suponemos que la mayoría
de los organismos biológicos son
bastante avaros con sus recursos ellos
no quieren desperdiciar sus recursos así
que si no hay lactosa entonces por qué
habrían de transcribir los genes que
pueden ser traducidos en enzimas para
metabolizar la lactosa así que si no hay
lactosa se podría ver esto como un
estado predeterminado
tenemos la proteína represor a la acc
enlazada al operador así que éste
el represor
por lo que no será posible transcribir
estos genes la polimerasa no podrá hacer
nada no va a ocurrir la transcripción
así que si no hay lactosa no ocurre la
transcripción no
ocurre
la
trans creep xian
lo cual tiene mucha lógica la bacteria
no quiere desperdiciar recursos así que
qué crees que sucederá si ahora sí hay
lactosa
si hay lactosa presente
ay
lactosa
presente
te puedes imaginar que ya no queremos
que el represor sigue estando ahí y eso
es precisamente lo que sucede tenemos un
isómero de lactosa llamado 'la ola' cosa
así que si la lactosa está presente
también vamos a tener a lola cosa
presente ésta es 'la ola' cosa
alo la cosa
que puede actuar como un inductor de la
transcripción y la forma en que actúa
como un inductor es si se une al
represor la acc el represor la que ya no
puede unirse al operador así que cuando
la lo lactosa está presente se unirá al
represor de modo que el represor va a
separarse del operador no va a ser capaz
de unirse al mismo tiempo
voy a dibujarlo por acá
este es el represor por aquí
tenemos a lola actos a que se ha unido
al represor y debido a eso el represor
no va a poder unirse al operador y
debido a que no está unido al operador
ahora la polimerasa va a poder
transcribir estos genes y eso es
importante porque mediante la
transcripción de estos genes la bacteria
va a ser capaz de metabolizar la lactosa
presente en el entorno por lo que si hay
lactosa presente entonces si ocurre la
transcripción
ocurre la
trans clic
ahora esta es una visión muy general de
lo perón la pero hay más porque hay
otros azúcares en particular glucosa que
es preferida por la célula así que vamos
a pensar en lo que sucederá en presencia
de glucosa y en la ausencia de glucosa
así que déjame escribir eso aquí
sin glucosa
y
con
glucosa
y recuerda la bacteria prefiere consumir
glucosa a consumir lactosa ya que la
glucosa es un azúcar más simple que la
lactosa así que si hay glucosa en el
entorno entonces por qué preocuparse por
la lactosa y podríamos hablar de estas
dos situaciones en presencia de lactosa
o en ausencia de lactosa
sino el actos alrededor entonces no
vamos a tener a los actos a alrededor
por lo que el represor va a estar unido
al operador y no va a ocurrir la
transcripción esto va a ocurrir
independientemente de si hay glucosa en
el entorno o no así que vamos a pensar
en que no hay glucosa pero si hay
lactosa sin glucosa más lactosa
y por acá tenemos glucosa más lactosa
si tenemos lácteos en el entorno
entonces vamos a tener a lo la ctc osa y
ya vimos este escenario la alo lactosa
se une al represor la que evita que el
represor la acc se una al operador por
lo que la arn polimerasa puede llevar a
cabo la transcripción pero eso no es
todo en una situación sin glucosa se va
a involucrar también al sitio cab vamos
a tener un activador que va a aumentar
esto aún más porque si no hay glucosa en
el entorno entonces la bacteria
realmente necesita la lactosa
y así aquí tenemos a la proteína
activadora de cata bonitos justo aquí la
proteína activadora de cata bonitos cup
y en presencia de a mp cíclico de
adenosina mono fosfato que es un
derivado del atp
este es el mp cíclico
y vas a ver que esta molécula aparece
mucho en la biología y en un momento más
hablaremos acerca de cómo se relaciona
el mp cíclico con la glucosa en
presencia del mp cíclico la proteína
activadora de cata bolitas se va a unir
al sitio cab y va a activar
aún más la transcripción así que en esta
situación sin glucosa más lactosa vamos
a tener que la transcripción aumenta aún
más permítanme escribir esto la
transcripción aumenta
la transcripción
aumenta
ahora sé lo que probablemente se están
preguntando esto es lo primero que me
pregunte cuando me hablaron del mp
cíclico cómo se relaciona el mp cíclico
con la glucosa bueno no voy a entrar en
mucho detalle pero lo que necesita saber
y tiene lógica es que si tenemos glucosa
si tenemos mucha glucosa
mucha glucosa
eso va a inhibir la producción de amv
cíclico
poco
a menos in mono fosfato cítrico
y si tenemos poca glucosa o nada de
glucosa no se va a inhibir la creación
de mp cíclico por lo que vamos a tener
mucho
mp cíclico
así que si no tenemos glucosa o tenemos
boca glucosa estamos en este escenario
justo aquí vamos a tener mayores
concentraciones de mp cíclico que pueden
unirse a la proteína activadora de cata
bolitas que entonces actúa como un
activador que aumenta la transcripción
del operón lac lo cual una vez más por
qué es importante bueno si no hay
glucosa o hay poca glucosa la bacteria
realmente va a necesitar la lactosa
realmente quiere transcribir estos genes
lo más rápido posible ahora qué pasa con
la situación donde hay glucosa y hay
lactosa bueno una vez más si hay lactosa
entonces vamos a tener a lola cosa que
va a unirse al represor lac y mediante
este enlace con el represor la acc el
represor lac no va a poder unirse al
operador por lo que una vez más la arn
polimerasa va a poder llevar a cabo la
transcripción
pero debido a que hay glucosa presente
va a haber poco a mp cíclico
y ya que hay poco o no hay a mp cíclico
alrededor el mp cíclico no va a poder
unirse a la proteína activadora de cata
bonitos por lo que la proteína
activadora de cata bonitos no va a poder
actuar como un activador así que no se
va a unir al sitio activador o al sitio
cab por lo que vamos a tener menos
transcripción
menos
trans cri
bien
lo cual tiene lógica hay glucosa y
lactosa alrededor la célula preferiría
utilizar la glucosa ya que es un azúcar
más simple y que la lactosa
pero por qué desperdicia recursos si hay
un montón de energía alrededor solo debe
de ir directamente a la glucosa pero si
no hay glucosa en el entorno entonces la
bacteria va a utilizar más recursos para
poder digerir la lactosa